no playing a second move first and I
just wanted to get secret Nazi six again
it's not a big problem with do you will
my daughter so born in by the way we are
doing this without h3 is kind of dicey
it doesn't even react to the move I
think this is Rosco always crazy someone
who played g5 against me I would think
for 10 seconds like what's going on here
g5 it just place a fox I mean this is
remarkable I was think that's remarkable
okay I could never do that myself it's
just would be completely irritated it's
obviously the most normal position ever
so yeah I know maybe you could have
played screen of three you it's really
annoying pinner relieve g8
mmm probably just takes them
I have to play at some point this isn't
great ready
I don't really see a do see an
alternative to that maybe you can play
g3 am Bishop h4h a g3
[Music]
against the drilling yeah
yeah this is just bad
it is just a bad position okay there's
almost no sensible way to unpinned us
this is stuff a pin was extremely
extremely annoying and he just allows me
to get rid of it if I go Queen g6 here
how does he cover g2 and everything 95
giving a piece on my background is also
extremely weak that could be some tactic
in his favor can ta de Quadra create I
haven't ridiculous bishop on a seven so
it's not completely easy
how do I ever get this activated in an
endgame that would be easy to do but i
have to weaken my king position he also
of its to to get this done
you should be eight going for you should
be aight i think i think that should
work take away the squares Andrew get to
next likely to actually has Luke h8 zone
and ya can check in and then we'll be
too yeah white we are I kind of games
really am unnerving it always you taste
with you to know and if I play in a
split second a five against g5 which is
it's a bit of a crazy move for new g5
and I know I always puts me totally off
if they ignore those kind of things and
what i do now probably is just rubbish
em it's probably really just rubbish
this now ng3 acting to screen f3 I mean
I was just so provoked that I played all
this nonsense now you can go Queen have
three simply Jim it's still too or
probably just lost this resource
when k played a couple of second best
moves but the position still totally
sucks but then the crazy thing was to
take on to take on f6 and take only four
I mean that it's not just technically
bad it just all so I mean if you now
just continues to strengthen the
position I can never unpin never and
maybe root g six or something edge is
terrible yeah this just gives it all
away okay so yeah it was a bad game now
boy it feel extremely provoked if they
ignore moves like okay and I shouldn't
be really but i'm at i'm almost almost
almost always am maybe this wasn't all
that terrible up to this point you
create it's probably a bit man it's not
the best way to play but it's probably
not not terrible yeah i want to lock you
in thanks for watching